so here's a report from daily wire
far-left climate extremist Greta
thunberg faced backlash on social media
for posting imagery that was widely
condemned as anti-semitic and
encouraging people to back organizations
that support the extermination of Israel
while posing in a photo with pro-
Palestinian activists week 270 thumberg
posted on on X today we strike in
solidarity with Palestine and Gaza the
world needs to speak up and call for an
immediate ceasefire Justice and freedom
for Palestinians and all civilians
affected
uh thunberg's message echoed statements
made by Islamic terrorist group Hamas
when they launched unprecedented Terror
attacks against Israel murdering more
than 1400
Israelis people in the photo held signs
that said free Palestine climate Justice
now stand with Gaza and climate Justice
now there we go free Palestine climate
Justice now this Jew stands with
Palestine stand with Gaza
okay so that was the picture and in fact
just keep the picture up on the screen
um because that led to uh a big backlash
from from many people including people
on the right who said that this was uh
anti-semitic I'm looking for the
exact let's see journalist Ian miles
Chong noted that a light blue stuff
octopus that is in the photo was a
reference to anti-semitic imagery that
has long been used to demonize the
Jewish people and the state of Israel
thumber claimed in a follow-up post that
she had no idea the stuffed animal in
the photo when with expressing support
for the group uh of people who just
committed terrorist attacks against
Israel could be interpreted as a symbol
for
anti-Semitism I was completely unaware
she claimed adding that the stuffed
animal was used by autistic people as a
way to communicate feelings so all right
so a couple things about this first of
all only demonstrates again it just
proves the point I was making at the top
of the headlines that this is uh in this
in in the west anyway uh GRE grber is
not from America thank God but in the
the West anyway uh they look at this
issue through a radical left-wing
filter and I mean you could probably
this exact photo if we were to go back
in 2020 we'd see almost this exact photo
with Greta thumberg and instead of free
Palestine it's BLM and the BLM fist it's
like it's the same thing to them they
don't see it as any different and that's
why she also you know you throw in
something like climate Justice and you
piggyback that onto the issue now what
in the world does climate what does
climate just mean first of all it's a
nonsensical concept what does the
climate have to do with what's happening
in Israel right now well it's all just
it's all part of the same jumble is
all so I want to show this picture
because it proves that point and also I
will say look far be it from me uh to
ever defend Greta fber in fact I don't
think I ever have in my life and so this
is going to be a first
but I I I I buy her excuse like I don't
think you know this is and I I know
there's people on the right and
conservatives that were jumping on this
and saying that uh that this is
anti-Semitic because of the
octopus now if you want to if you want
to point out that well you're you got
that free Palestine uh you know you the
message of free Palestine we're standing
with uh Palestine after uh all those
Israeli civilians were just
murdered and you want to point out how
how horrific and awful that is agree
but when it comes to the octopus
specifically uh this is something even
though we there's some conservatives
that are jumping on the bandwagon and
say oh the octopus it's anti-semitic
imagery this is something you find on
the left a lot where they you know
someone takes a picture and they're
doing and there's something really
seemingly innocuous in the picture and
then the left
says oh that's that's bigoted that's
racist uh because that you know image or
that thing you're doing with your hand
you know that that that hand gesture is
l linked to some uh white supremacist
Trope and most of the time you you hear
them making this connection sometimes
they're just inventing the connection
but even if it's true it's like who knew
that that's really obscure who knew I
had no idea so so the so the octopus
imagery is linked to anti-semitic
imagery in the past I had I had no clue
about this Association I would I would
venture to Guess that 99% of people if
you ask them whether the octopus is
linked to anti-semitic imagery I think
99% of people would say what octopus
what does that to do with anything I'm
still a little bit confused about what
the what the association is there so
it's a pretty obscure Association I
think we can agree or she'll be able to
agree um is that what Greta thunberg was
trying to convey or is it her is her
excuse the more plausible scenario which
is that it helps her communicate
feelings that actually that sounds like
something thumberg would do that she
would she have her her emotional support
stuffed animal with her to help her to
help her in this emotionally trying
time that actually that that tracks with
me I'm I'm more than willing to believe
that for her if you run a small business
you need to plan ahead one of the best
ways to do that is by using stamps.com
for all of your mailing and shipping
needs stamps.com let you print your own
Postage and shipping labels right from
your home or office space it's
incredibly convenient your shipping
labels are ready to go in minutes so you
can get back to running your business
sooner we don't waste time here at Del
wire we have use stamps.com since 2017
our office management staff loves
stamps.com because they don't have to
spend hours at the post office
stamps.com offers rates you can't find
anywhere else like up to 84% off U USPS
and UPS plus they will automatically
tell you your cheapest and fastest
shipping options for 25 years stamps.com
has been indispensable to over 1 million
businesses you can print postage
wherever you do business no lines no
traffic no waiting they even send you a
free scale so you'll have everything you
need to get started set your business up
for Success get started with stamps.com
today sign up with promo code Walsh for
a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and
free digital scale no long-term
commitment or contracts required just go
to stamps.com Click the microphone at
the top of the page and enter code
wolsh in either way I mean even if this
was even if having the octopus stuffed
animal there was supposed to be some
kind of obscure subliminal uh
anti-semitic thing it it's it just as a
strategic
standpoint um it's best to ignore it
because you you sound overly sensitive
and
crazy uh by harping on that say oh that
stuffed octopus is anti-Semitic so if it
was intentional then she was it was bait
and she was putting the seemingly
innocuous thing there to try to bait the
other side into matching on to it and
accusing her of being anti-semitic for
something that she could then turn
around and say what are you talking
about it's just it's a it's an it's
stuffed to octopus is
all so worst case scenario it was bait
and then by latching on to it then you
have fallen for the bait if You' like to
see what else I have to say you can
access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there God speed